um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi hello
thank you for joining me for an episode
of
polylogs
um
so we have no small subject um
that being the history of computer
science
waiting in and seeing where it goes
um
but maybe i should ask you to position
yourself in the the timeline first like
how would you say that you became
a computer scientist
okay i i i mean it seems pompous to
position myself in the whole history of
computer science but uh
i mean okay i i
uh joined
you know i mean i i uh uh
um started studying at the undergraduate
level in
1996 i guess but i uh
um
i wanted to uh create my own video games
mostly i mean i mean that was that was
what uh uh um
hooked me as a kid
uh that you know that that a a a
nintendo game seemed like this whole
universe and miniature right and yet you
know unlike the physical universe uh
someone completely understood that
universe because someone had created it
right or you know so i mean you know
some someone who you could uh actually
go and talk to right and uh
um you know and and it seemed like if i
could understand how how games work how
you would create your own game uh then
yeah i would really understand something
deep but uh uh i um i didn't have the
idea of universality right so i imagined
that it was some kind of complicated
engineering
and um
you know even um
you know you know maybe maybe you need a
giant factory to uh you know assemble
programs or something you know when i
first saw what programming was uh when i
was 11 or so it was a revelation it was
kind of like learning where babies come
from right it was like why didn't anyone
tell me this earlier uh it
um
uh you know just just just that
there's this simple set of instructions
and and once you learn them that's it
right that's all you know it's all just
a matter of how you combine them
and
uh you know and it was an even bigger
revelation you know to learn that that
uh
the church touring thesis right that
it's not just that there's this one
programming language but then you know
later i'm going to learn a more advanced
programming language with which you
could express things that you couldn't
possibly express in the first one right
and so on and so on forever i said no
once you've learned your first
programming language you have learned
you know the entire rule set that
governs every computer that's ever been
created
right uh all the programming languages
can emulate each other you know in some
formal sense they're all equivalent to
each other
just you know some are more convenient
you know and all the computers that have
been built are are
equivalent in some sense it's just that
some are faster or slower some have more
or less memory
and so so so there's just this tiny set
of rules that you need to learn about
you know reading and writing symbols and
the changing state and
moving around in memory and uh things
like that and
some sense uh once you've learned them
then then
at least formally you've learned the
rules for anything in the universe
right that is pretty wonderful
no i mean i mean i uh i i did you know
when i was a teenager think of you know
becoming a software developer of some
kind or
you know maybe starting a company uh but
you know i i sort of got uh disabused of
those notions you know by uh
um
finding out you know
just how much better uh other people
were that than i was at sort of uh
maintaining large amounts of code you
know uh documenting their code getting
it done on time getting their code to
work with other people's code you know
and all of those you know different very
hard aspects of software engineering and
of projects and uh uh you know if i was
you know and i i i got more and more
sort of word for better or worse to the
to the mathematical side of things
just just trying to understand what's
possible
and um
yeah and and uh
here i still am a you know quarter of a
century later
to get down to sort of the the
fundamentals um
you know how do you define computing or
computer science
uh yeah so so the famous quote from
dykstra i said that computer science is
no more about computers than astronomy
is about telescopes
right uh you know it is uh
uh you know the uh uh um computer
science is uh uh well it it's the study
of
uh uh let's say
what what what what you can do with uh
uh you know precise sets of rules right
with uh uh uh computations meaning you
know just uh sort of manipulations of
symbols according to rules right and uh
you know in that way it is very very
closely allied with math
in fact you know from for
for most of history uh i think computer
science would have been very hard to
distinguish from that um
but uh you know it has a different uh
aesthetic maybe and a different focus
uh because you know the uh um the
you know on on
um unlike in math you know our goal was
not just proving that things exist
you know it is always sort of figuring
out how to uh construct those things and
then even more concretely than that you
know figuring out like what resources
you need to you know to actually uh
uh find you know the prime factorization
of a number or find uh you know the
shortest path uh through a graph or or
anything like that and so so i would i
think of computer science as a continuum
now at one extreme of the continuum it
simply is math
right i mean a
a
theoretical computer science you know
could be seen as just a branch of math
um
but uh uh which which which would make
sense sort of give you know under the
definition that i've given but then at
the other extreme uh it is engineering
because you are you're concerned with
building actual devices that will uh uh
that will that will implement these
mathematical ideas you know that will uh
uh sort of breathe fire into them so to
speak
and
um
uh
so you know there is you know there
there's there's i mean i mean
people like to say that nothing with the
word science in its name really is one
right
and uh you know computer science uh well
you know i i i i i it it it it it's a
it's a
maybe maybe an uninteresting semantic
question what you choose to call science
right i mean if if science has to be
empirical i mean computer science does
have an empirical aspect in that uh you
are often you know using computers to
experiment right you are trying things
out you are running a program you're
seeing what happens it's different from
experimenting with nature right because
you know in some sense everything that
happens is you know in principle
completely determined you know by this
program that you wrote and if only you
were smart enough you would have seen it
all at first okay but uh it is uh it
shares with science you know the uh the
the feature that you you constantly get
results that you didn't expect you know
that tell you that your initial guess
was wrong right so there is sort of
something that you are looking at you
know like let's say the output of your
computer program that pushes back
against you you know that forces you to
revise your your original ideas
uh so it doesn't have that empirical
aspect you know that that could justify
the name science maybe uh but then you
know i would say it and um
um you know the writer paul graham said
computer science is a little bit like
yugoslavia right it's like these
different things put together by
accident of history right so you know at
one extreme you have pure math and at
the other extreme you have engineering
building building actual devices uh you
know testing the devices uh trying to
break the devices you know see if
they're secure or insecure
um so it's um it's all of that and uh
um you know it it's um
you know like like in in the in the
uh i guess in the in the uh uh
from from from an outsider's point of
view you know the field is uh um
inextricably uh linked with these actual
devices you know the ones that i'm you
know using to talk to you right now for
example you know and that and that's
natural because these devices have you
know uh you know you know
we we do actually build them now and you
know they have changed the face of
civilization uh but i i would say that
you know computer science existed even
before there were computers
right uh it's it's more it's it's it's
broader than than
these you know uh uh um you know these
uh devices with silicon chips right uh
you can you know you can see computation
in the brain you can see it in markets
you can see it in uh quantum mechanical
systems uh so it so it really is you
know a sort of
a way of looking at
uh just about anything in the world
right
yeah um and so you like to think of the
the sort of the arc of the history of
computer science and and you did your
your timeline for mit's anniversary um
which was i guess almost um 10 years ago
but
um no it started with euclid and
basically ends with
you know now as you say the zoom
algorithm or what have you and then it
has ada lovelace and don knuth in
between
um like how do you
think of the history of computer science
broadly speaking or what did that
process of doing that timeline which
must have seemed like quite a daunting
task what did that yeah i mean i was i
was asked to make a timeline with the
sort of most important you know
150 milestones in the history of
computer science and you know you know
any exercise like that is a little bit
of a
you know a forward game right uh you
know there's no objective answer about
what were the most important things
but so i i decided to look at what other
people had done and uh you know who what
what um
uh
had people considered you know to be
important milestones i knew that i
wanted a mixture of uh theoretical
advances of uh practical advances in
computing you know that the average
person would know about and and sort of
everything in between
um
but uh uh
what what i didn't want was uh um
uh milestones like you know the uh you
know the one millionth floppy disk or
something right you know that are just
some arbitrary numerical you know thing
or i didn't want
uh things you know that had to do with
the public recognition of of uh
computing like you know time magazine
naming a computer it's person of the
year or whatever right uh you know i
wanted uh sort of the the the
introduction of concepts that that ended
up being important right you know
weather weather whether for better or
for worse right so i have uh uh i think
i think in my list i had uh the time
hierarchy theorem which is a fundamental
result you know from the 60s that says
that when you have more time you can
compute more functions than if you have
less time you know basically right so
there's not like a a largest amount of
time that you need to compute everything
right and you know and then i also had
like you know the introduction of the
mac and of windows and of uh
um i think i had i had the stocks
network
right uh which is
what targeted the the iranian
centrifuges i had you know uh uh
milestones about you know the the you
know the introduction of uh
the major social media platforms right
so so there were things that like the
the average person would have heard of
and there were things that the
the
the the average person would not have
heard of but maybe you know due to
people in in
you know within the field would have
been sort of the deeper things that that
you know maybe all the other stuff was
downstream of
um
and
um you know i had i actually had more
than 150 milestones and then i had
readers of my blog vote on them so
you know uh to sort of
narrow it down to 150.
um so you know i don't know if the list
is good or not but it was you know i
just tried to uh answer the charge that
i was given by this uh mit celebration
committee at the time
yeah oh it's fascinating reading and
there's some um as you say there's some
nice surprises in there and you know
scentsy yeah yeah no i mean there was
also
there i mean there was also the question
of just how far back do you go in
history right right so you know i i had
something about the uh the antikythera
mechanism which was this astronomical
computer you know really really amazing
one from about 2 000 years ago that was
dredged out of the ocean
uh uh you know dredged out of the
mediterranean
um you know i i had uh um you know so i
think you know something about about
about euclid i had about liveness about
uh babbage right but then you know
obviously the pace of milestones picks
up enormously as you get into the 20th
century uh uh you know and then it just
reaches this um
uh uh
you know
extreme rate in let's say the sixties
and seventies um iran uh um um a little
bit worryingly the pace of milestones
that i uh found you know worth
mentioning seem to have slowed more
recently i mean it could just be a
matter of you know what
once we have more hindsight than we'll
be able to identify the things that are
happening now that that you know that
ended up being historically important
right
i mean if i were if i were making that
list today i would certainly include for
example the gpt-3 text engine right
which was just the
loose on the world a couple of months
ago
right and just wrote an op-ed in the
guardian arguing for his own existence
did you see that i guess yeah i did see
that yes
are arguing why it's not harmful to
humans
yeah
only only occasionally straying from the
topic
yeah the scariest part of that for me
was that that the editors found it was
it was much more easy to edit the
the ai's
right good sign for for writers um
but
so
yeah coming up more into our present day
um like over the course of your career
what advancements have have really
surprised you or have changed your own
trajectory
um
well i mean
uh maybe the obvious thing for me would
be uh quantum computing right i mean
this is uh you know what what i've been
doing for you know
almost the whole time i've been in
theoretical computer science right but
when i when i learned when i first
learned about uh uh
computer science uh about the
theory of computer science as a teenager
uh you know i mean uh you know i i
learned about p and np and about np
completeness and um
you know it seemed like there was more
than enough richness there to you know
occupy a person further for their whole
life
and uh
uh um um quantum computing was this
weird thing that you know i i read about
in uh popular articles and there was
some guy named peter shore who
discovered some algorithm for you know
allegedly for quickly factoring huge
numbers with you know this a different
kind of computer and you know thereby
breaking uh the encryption that we
currently use
and my first reaction to it was you know
the the this sounded like garbage right
this sounded like some physicists who
just did not understand the enormity of
what they were up against that uh
uh um
you know the the church touring thesis
right that basically you know everything
is touring computation and you know if
if someone uh uh you know the experience
in computer science over decades have
been that if someone claims something uh
from from from physics that that isn't
that is not sort of uh reducible to
touring computation or simulatable like
by a touring machine then you know
they're just wrong right they have you
know sort of idealized some aspect of
the laws of physics that once you look
at it more closely then um you know then
then a compute you know a perfectly
conventional computer can simulate it
right but uh uh you know i i decided at
some point that i had to learn what this
quantum computing was
and um
you know what i found was okay well well
uh
uh uh first of all you know in terms of
you know it doesn't change the laws of
what is computable right anything that's
computable by a quantum computer is also
computable by an ordinary computer okay
but it might you know wildly change the
laws of what is efficiently computable
right
so you could uh you might be able to do
things with a quantum computer with uh
only a polynomial scaling like a
you know an amount of time increases
only linearly or quadratically with the
size of your problem where a classical
computer would need time that grows
exponentially with the size of the
problem and you know the way that you
would do that is by exploiting uh
uh this you know uh amazing discovery
that was made a century ago which is
that you know the the world is uh
uh is quantum mechanical uh you know
that if you want to describe a
physical system
you you can't just say where all the
particles are you need to give this not
not complex number called an amplitude
uh for every possible way that the
particles could be
okay so
uh so you know for just a thousand
particles there might be you know two to
the thousand power or even more ways
that they could be and every possible
way that they could be gets another one
of these amplitudes right now that's an
absolutely staggering claim about about
physics uh you know it it um
you know
um but but but as far as a century of uh
physical experiments can tell it seems
to be correct
right and you know it's it's amazing in
a way that it took as long as it did for
people to start asking well what does
that mean for computation
right but uh but that was um that was
that was a real change to
to my world view i mean once i realized
you know what you know sort of the what
quantum mechanics was and that it was
saying something of you know of
comparable enormity to uh what church
and touring had said you know about
about computation
uh then you know it became clear well
yeah if if quantum mechanics is right
then sure in principle you should be
able to build these quantum computers
uh you know if the more radical
possibility would be if you can't build
them right if if there's some reason why
quantum computers would not work then
that that would actually be a revolution
in physics you know if they couldn't
uh you know the idea that they can be
built is just a conservative possibility
and um you know quantum computing was a
new
field at the time and so there was a
there were a lot of very very basic open
questions and so i got interested in it
i thought
uh you know i mean as long as
you know uh one is doing theoretical
computer science anyway right and you
know where it's a
it's a study of you know that's often
very very far removed from practical
applications
right then um
[Music]
you know one one might as well ask you
know what do the known laws of physics
imply about the ultimate limits of
computation or of efficient computation
right uh uh you know and and and that
was really the motivation for me i mean
uh you know i mean i hope that we'll see
practical quantum computers i hope that
they'll be useful for something but all
of that is really icing on the cake
right i mean
uh uh
the the the the the point is really you
know that that there is this uh uh
um
merger between physics and computation
right that uh
uh um you know people trying to
understand quantum mechanics people
trying to understand computation two of
you know the most fundamental things
that you could possibly ask about right
you know now have this channel where
they can talk to each other and often
they need to talk to each other
and so that that was that was a uh uh
a a uh uh you know a a revelation to me
and that sort of uh you know uh uh
obviously changed the trajectory of my
career
um
yeah i mean i could talk about other
surprises but maybe i should let you go
on um well
so what would you say is the
is the most important contribution
you've made then in that in that field
um well okay i mean i mean probably the
the uh thing that i did that had the
most
you know obvious uh uh sort of
uh broader impact to use the the the
nsf's you know uh bureaucratic term for
it uh it uh would be uh the uh the work
that that i did with colleagues on sort
of establishing the theoretical
foundations for what's called quantum
supremacy
okay
quantum supremacy means you know the
uh the use of a quantum computer which
may be a small
noisy quantum computer you know but sort
of the first use of a quantum computer
to do
something this uh that is that we're
pretty sure is hard to stimulate using a
classical computer
okay now note that i did not say
something useful
uh you know uh
uh the um
problem being solved uh can be a
completely contrived benchmark okay but
you could think of it as analogous to
you know the wright brothers airplane or
to enrico fermi's you know nuclear chain
reaction right the goal is to prove the
point that you know we can build a
quantum computer
and you know it can it can solve some
well-defined problem much faster than
anyone knows how to solve that same
problem with a classical computer okay
and and not only that but you can do
that for for reasons that are uh
tied to its being a quantum computer
right so you know no no one can explain
how it's doing the thing much faster
without making reference to this
exponential number of amplitudes you
know that i that i talked about before
uh so that's that's what quantum
supremacy means the the actual term was
coined by john preschool in 2012 and
it's stuck for better or worse not not
not not everyone likes the term but uh
um
but you know but but uh um
some of us had been thinking about you
know what what became known as as
quantum supremacy you know from uh
you know 2009 2010 or so and you know in
particular um you know it started as a
very theoretical study of uh
just you know how hard of a a
computational problem say in the sense
of complexity theory can you encode into
the amplitudes of a of a quantum
computation right so uh so so it started
with the fairly arcane questions in a
quantum complexity theory but uh uh just
you know in order to create a quantum
computation that had um
like certain like hard functions called
permanence of matrices uh in the
amplitudes uh
my student alex archipob and i we're
glad to study uh systems of identical
bosons uh such as photons right uh that
would pass through some network of uh
beam splitters and then get measured
right and so this was a proposal that we
call boson sampling okay and
uh uh you know after we had sort of
proved the these theorems about this
proposal uh what surprised us was that
all of these experimental quantum optics
people got all excited about it right
and they were like well you know uh
you're talking about bosons well you
know we have bosons in our web right we
have you know we we we do exactly this
we generate uh we can generate single
photons we can send them through beam
splitter for networks and so maybe we
could try to demonstrate quantum
supremacy right try to demonstrate doing
you know the first computation that
would be hard to simulate with a
classical computer
and so so they managed to do boson
sampling like first with three photons
then with five six most recently with 14
photons now to actually outperform a
classical computer you would need um at
least let's say 60 70 or uh maybe a
hundred photons okay and so so uh so so
they're they're they're not there yet
okay but in the meantime something else
happened which was that around um
2015 uh uh
the uh google uh hired uh john martinez
who was um you know maybe uh the most
famous uh super conducting qubits uh
experimentalist in the world uh to form
a group to actually try to build
scalable quantum computers based on
superconducting qubits
and
um uh you know and and so
so they they came up with a plan where
you know that they they thought that
they could make a a chip with 50 to 70
programmable qubits right and just to
put this in context i mean what we hoped
for eventually is you know millions of
qubits right that would be fully error
corrected that would last as long as you
need them to right now we're talking
about 50 or 60 qubits uh that are not at
all error corrected right so they're
very noisy okay but
uh you know they they actually do behave
as qubits for you know an appreciable
amino enough time to do uh you know
maybe a couple dozen layers of
operations right so they you know you
you know you they're fully programmable
20 years ago i mean the experimentalists
were mostly playing around with one or
two cubits
right that when ones that were much
noisier than these 50 or 60 cubits okay
so
so you know things had really come a
long way okay but uh but then you know
the the question that confronted the
theme at google was once we built this
chip you know with 50 or so cubits you
know supposing it worked what do we do
with it right uh
um you know it's not clear that there's
anything especially useful that you can
do with such a chip there might or might
not be but can we at least prove that
it's getting a speed up over a classical
computer can we at least sort of prove
the point that you know uh uh quantum
speed ups are real you know that that
that they can work uh you know can we
demonstrate this milestone of quantum
supremacy and so they
um they they decided to really target
that as a goal you know that was not an
obvious decision you know ibm and others
that quantum supremacy is irrelevant we
don't care about it okay but uh google
said we're going to go for this but you
know how do we do it and they said we
want to do something like poses on
sampling okay but you know more tailored
to our super conducting qubits
so we talked to them
and we came up with a proposal for you
know that we became known as random
circuit sampling and it was just sort of
the simplest
benchmark that you know sort of aligned
with the uh
the
details of their system and then they
said you know look you know
rather than adapting our
you know hardware to your theory uh we
want you to adapt your theory to our
hardware
so
you know uh you know you your theorists
seem cheaper right so uh so so can you
do that and we said yes yes we uh we
think we can do that so then we did some
you know theoretical analysis of uh um
you know of this random circuit sampling
like if you know supposing that google
is able to do this uh how should you
verify the results and how hard would it
then be for a classical computer to
scoop those results you know can we
prove under some reasonable
computational assumptions that you know
that spoofing with a classical computer
is hard so we did that analysis and um
you probably know the uh the conclusion
of the story which was just about a year
ago
google actually managed to demonstrate
this this quantum supremacy with
53 cubits uh it um
you know it it you know they they the
the
the signal that they can extract is tiny
they have to repeat millions of times
you know they have to take millions of
samples in order to be even be able to
extract a statistical signal uh of of
for
of quantum supremacy uh but uh but even
you know repeating millions of times
right they can do that in about three
minutes and you know using the largest
super computer you the largest classical
supercomputers that are on earth
um
you know it seems like it would take at
the very least a few days you know to do
the same thing and that would be with
hundreds of thousands of parallel
processors
you know as opposed to just this one uh
superconducting chip so so that was the
demonstration of quantum supremacy uh
you know nature
featured it on uh you know it's a 150th
anniversary cover right so uh you know i
think it was a huge milestone for the
field for science and just to be clear
you know i uh uh was not part of the
engineering team that uh
uh
uh that achieved this but uh you know
i'm you know i'm very proud that uh some
of the theory that we did that started
as very abstruse complexity theory you
know actually ended up being relevant to
an actual experiment you know i mean
that's the nice union of the
theoretical and the engineering yeah
um
and so where do you see things going
from here like what's top of mind for
you currently
first of all uh figuring out you know uh
you know you know in in the coming years
we're going to have quantum computers
that will not be fully scalable right or
fully error corrected but they may have
a hundred qubits 200 300 cubits
um
you know of a good enough quality that
you could maybe start to do something
useful
uh but what
right and uh
what
what do you do with them uh you know are
you
are you really sure that you're getting
an advantage over a classical computer
uh you know now a a huge downside of the
uh uh quantum supremacy demonstration
that was done right or the the the stuff
like boson sampling like random circuit
sampling is that verifying the results
of these computations you know is is is
itself extremely hard right uh you see
you have to do an extremely expensive
classical computation and an exponential
time one actually just to verify that
the quantum computer did what it was
supposed to do
right now you know of course the
classical computation you can do at your
leisure right you can uh you know you
can take as much time as you need to
verify what the quantum computer did
very quickly but uh you could say you
know i'm um ultimately you know you're
not uh uh we we with with these ideas
we're never gonna you know be able to
use a quantum computer to uh uh
to to to do something that is you know
that would have been impossible with our
classical computers and know that it was
impossible with them because if if so
then we wouldn't have even be able to
verify the answer with our classical
computers right so uh so so you know now
you know the the first you know
super famous quantum algorithm you know
uh uh
to be discovered i guess you know
shore's factoring algorithm did not have
this this feature because when you find
the prime factors of an enormous number
then you know you
anyone can easily check
the results right like if you've or if
you've broken a cryptic system if you
you know you can
get you know a a
decrypt someone's message uh you know at
that point you know that person doesn't
have to uh
uh take your word for it that you have a
quantum computer right there they're
they're they're they're they're scared
anyway right you can just show them that
you can you can show them the the
decrypted message um
so
uh but but but the the trouble is that
shore's algorithm seems to require
you know uh fully error corrected qubits
and many thousands of them before you're
going to be able to break uh uh uh
encryption in that way and that's that's
uh
probably not in the next decade you know
i would be very surprised if we would do
such things in the next decade but uh
you know with these sort of noisy
intermediate scale devices that we're
going to see you know what can we do
that is interesting
where we can actually quickly check the
answer to it and ideally where it's even
useful for someone okay so this is a
major place where uh uh theory is going
to be playing a role you know in the in
the coming years uh so that that that i
would say is on the more practical side
you know on the more theoretical side um
i've gotten more and more interested uh
over the last decade in uh
what's called the the uh the it from
cupid uh uh uh collaboration which
actually comes from the the uh or is
funded by the simons foundation
this is an effort to bring together
quantum computing and quantum
information theory with uh quantum
gravity with you know the people who
study the black hole information problem
and uh
spring theory and ads cft
and you know an amazing thing that has
happened over the last decade is that
the people who worry about you know how
does information get out of a black hole
and these very deep questions like that
have started talking about those
questions in the language of qubits and
quantum circuits and quantum computation
and polynomial time
and you know
uh uh and and then you know they they've
they've started coming to us with
questions and you know i am uh uh uh uh
certainly not a string theorist you know
by any you know stretch of the
imagination my uh uh
um you know my my um
you know i have i have very embarrassing
gaps in my knowledge of physics okay but
i've
i've tried to help the quantum gravity
people as a sort of uh
theoretical computer science consultant
right so so you know again and again
they have come come up with questions
that are actually phrased in in a
language that i understand
and you know i've been able to
collaborate with them this is uh people
like like lenny suskin who's really been
the the leader of this effort um
um daniel harveau um you know and uh
really uh
um
high-energy physicists or you know a uh
string theorist quantum gravity
theorists who are more and more learning
the language of computer science so i'll
probably you know continue thinking
about those sorts of questions too
fascinating yeah that's no shortage of
food for thought there
i mean we also have lots and lots of you
know old open problems just about you
know quantum complexity classes and how
they relate to each other and of course
i would still like to
pick off some of those
right yeah
yeah did you find anything worrisome
about the direction that computer
science is going or does it seem to
check itself i find a lot worrying about
the direction that the world is going in
and you know a a
computer science is you know
you know like like all of research all
of science is is uh
um you know dependent on the rest of
society right i'm human that's
because like when when when people ask
you know peop
people constantly ask me to try to
forecast well you know how many years
until we have a useful quantum computer
right and you know i've i've gotten good
at sort of [ __ ] my way around that
kind of question i like to say like if
if i had you know any of
you know in
in some sense like you know we can say
an enormous amount about
you know enormously more about the
eventual destination that we're heading
towards than about sort of the exact
technological path to get to that
destination right because you know the
um
uh
uh you know a a
i mean once you have a scalable quantum
computer then you know
the
uh the the question of what you can
can't do with it is math
right it's uh uh
and you know we can we can do that math
you know now we can do it with you know
much of it you know without having the
computer uh but you know to forecast the
the uh twists and turns that technology
is going to take you know to actually
get you know to that threshold of
quantum universality of you know a fully
programmable you know and fully uh error
corrected quantum computer that's
incredibly hard and that depends on all
kinds of things like how much money
people want to spend on it you know
whether there is another great
depression whether there's you know
uh you know
what
what
whether there's some pandemic that you
know cripples civilization
yeah you know hypothetical possibility
right uh
it it depends on so many things that are
that are really hard to forecast or uh
control
um
you know so i mean
to the extent that i worry those are
those are mostly the things that i worry
about
um um you know i i think that uh uh you
know if uh you know in in
like when you're when you're doing math
or or theoretical computer science like
it's it's it's you you can you can have
a ver a very good feeling about it in
the sense that uh you know the the you
know the uh progress can be incredibly
hard you know sometimes it can take uh
years decades you know even centuries uh
to to solve a math problem but uh the
amazing thing is that the progress only
goes in one direction
right
all right
you can you can see you know you know
you don't you don't lose
a ground that you've gained right and uh
uh you know and a lot of the things that
were that were open problems when i was
a student uh uh 20 years ago are now no
longer open problems you know of of
course we have new problems right but
but uh um
you know
to the extent that this
you know uh process is uh uh um
uh uh um able to continue at all that
society is able to support it at all you
know i do feel pretty good that the
process works
maybe you know not as quickly as we
would like maybe we can get it to work
quicker but you know uh uh you know
uh uh
the uh um you know the amazing thing
about math you know and what you know i
i mean i i also like sometimes talking
about philosophy talking about questions
that might never be answered right but
you know in math you know we have these
questions that sometimes seem
unanswerable but then you know a lot of
them actually do get
answered mm-hmm yeah
yeah nice surprise
great great
thank you very much for no problem you
all right okay bye
[Music]
you